i hate attack on titan after following
the series for seven or so years now
that's the only reasonable conclusion
that i can come to and i could go into
every facet about why i feel this way
but i think it's best epitomized by
one moment a moment where an overzealous
bloodthirsty little parasite that i
barely know
can shoot a beloved potato girl but what
i hate is that despite all of the pain
and loss
i am still primarily left with the
feeling that gabi was justified in doing
so hello and welcome to the new order of
your source for everything anime and
manga and today we are here to dive into
my complex feelings regarding attack on
titan a series where i don't think the
words love and hate are so mutually
exclusive and more specifically why the
latest at the time of this recording
episode of season 4 encapsulates this
experience pretty perfectly but for a
bit of fun we're going to start off with
a slice of democracy i understand that
young gabi will have caused quite a stir
in the anime community perhaps even the
world at large given what's trending on
twitter so here's the deal
if you think that gabi was justified in
her actions then please do show your
support by hitting the subscribe button
for the new world review which will also
result in regular anime perhaps even
attack on titan content uploaded
straight into your youtube feed or
if you think that gabi is some kind of
satanic hellspawn who deserves nothing
but a swift yet painful death for the
crime of taking a beloved sasha away
from us then please do show your support
for that
by subscribing to the new world review
and then i'll go away calculate those
votes and we'll just see where we end up
but for the purpose of this video i have
already run a less scientific
inclination of this poll in my community
section which has a fairly even split
actually with slightly more people
in favor of gabi's decision of course i
did make this poll quite deliberately
blunt it has no room for nuance
whatsoever because that's just not how
war works
in the moment there is no time for
nuance so i wanted to know where people
stood on that sort of level as for where
i stand like i quite blatantly stated in
the intro this is the sort of situation
that makes me
hate attack on titan not because the
series is bad i actually think it's been
incredibly solidly put together and i
hope that we do keep this up all the way
till the end but i hate that this series
forces me into some very uncomfortable
territory regarding morality and usually
lands in quite a depressing and
unsatisfactory place which is pretty
perfect for this series which aims to
explore deeper aspects of humanity by
juxtaposing them against giant monsters
and then always asking
us the question of well who are the real
monsters here and the correct answer is
often
literally everyone but our monster of
the hour this time around is gabi and i
want to hate her i really do
aside from levi sasha was easily my
favorite character in this entire
hell hole of a series and i highly doubt
that i'm alone in that feeling sasha was
like a beacon of this
potato-generated light in a swamp of
morally questionable protagonists who
only continue to become more and more
bogged down with every decision they
make and i suppose that's exactly why
sasha had to die there was no other
character on that airship that gabi
could have killed which would have had
more impact on the audience than sasha
someone who i would say
at least anecdotally is universally
loved seriously i think gabi could have
shot amin mikasa
connie jean maybe not levi but almost
anyone else on that airship could have
been killed and it would have generated
less outrage than killing sasha there
are even some people gabi could have
shot that might have generated some form
of celebration i mean personally if
she'd shot aaron i'd be all on board
with team garby or if she'd killed flock
then i
really can't imagine that there are a
lot of hardcore flock stands out there
that would have taken to twitter to vent
against her and in fact we have a
tangible example of this hypothetical
from this very episode because everyone
is so saturated with thoughts about gabi
and sasha but almost nobody seems to
stop and think about lobov he was killed
by gabi as well and absolutely
no one anywhere cares not even me i'm
sorry lobov
i don't care but the reason why gabi is
an issue at all is because she
killed sasha and thus took something
precious to us as a result gabi is now
the devil incarnate who exists only to
cause us pain and must be punished with
ever so violent yet satisfying justice
it's a very similar feeling to the one
that we began the series with aaron's
mother
was killed and so we channeled our anger
into enacting some form of justice onto
the titans they were the undisputed
villains completely void of any humanity
irredeemable creatures that were good
for nothing
except for being sliced to pieces and
being eradicated from existence which i
find very interesting because our
initial feelings towards the titans are
almost an exact mirror of gabi's
philosophy regarding the aldians on the
island
gabi quite literally refers to this
group of people as devils with that same
sort of intense hatred that we are
intimately familiar
with being generated from aaron
specifically but not exclusively and the
only reason why we're not so much on
gabi's side here is because we've now
spent three whole seasons with these
devils and we understand that they are
no such thing they are wildly imperfect
humans the same brands that you will
find on mali just with a funky innate
titan ability which leads me to one of
the most
annoying conclusions i've ever had to
grapple with in the series which is
basically that garby is
aaron the garby we see now in season 4
is pretty much a carbon copy of where
aaron was in season one where he begins
his rage filled titan slaughtering
journey without a single care for who
these titans are or may have been and
why they did the things they did
and yeah i know aaron's case is a bit
more clear-cut because he was fighting
literal monsters but hey eventually it
comes out that there was a lot more to
titans than meets the eye as it turns
out these titans were once human and
we'd been slaughtering primarily
innocent victims of circumstance and
gabi hasn't quite reached the
realization aspect of her journey yet in
fact
she's nowhere near it she's still in
that blind indoctrination phase where to
her seeing
say sasha is no different from being
confronted with a literal titan monster
that is threatening to destroy her and
everything she loves and in that way i
think gabi's actions are entirely
justified from her perspective
to us as the audience yes she is an
idiot child making an already terrible
situation
much much worse with her ignorant
bloodlust but that's only because we
have the benefit of knowledge and
context though from gabi's perspective
she is the
like protagonist who saw her friends get
crushed by titan debris and has sworn
revenge on the ones who caused it just
as erin did after witnessing his
mother's death and to me there is no
difference between child aaron and child
gabi which
actually i guess is the only garbi we
currently have access to gabi just got
the opportunity to act on her blind
desires before aaron did in the grand
scheme of things which is a very
interesting hypothetical let's go back
to season one and ask ourselves if young
aaron had equipped himself with a weapon
went hunting and found say reina after
he'd reverted back to being a human and
then killed him would we not be praising
child aaron i mean if anything at that
point he would be hailed as a hero the
child who brought down a villainous
murderous armored titan there would be
no moral question attached to it at all
so when we get to season four and aaron
does
the exact same thing that rainer did by
attacking a society for what he believes
to be a purpose of greater good
am i going to blame the new eren that he
creates as a result of that
and my answer is absolutely not gabi is
simply doing what she thought was
justified and thinking exclusively from
her perspective that is
very hard to argue with especially
because aaron at this stage is 100
an antagonist like we all get that right
the moment he decided to kill innocent
civilians for
whatever purpose this turns out to be he
was lost i don't think there's any
redemption for him and just as he said
to rainer they
are now the same which in a really
intriguingly twisted way now sort of
makes guard be our protagonist because
she is the latest victim in this vicious
cycle a cycle where she was radicalized
by the actions of eren who was
radicalized by the actions of rainer who
was radicalized by his society which was
radicalized by the actions of ancient
elder it's a cycle that spans
i think thousands of years and gabi is
just our latest descendant of that
so my question becomes now that aaron is
irredeemable will it actually be up to
gabi to be the one to break this cycle
right now looks like gabi is on the
exact same path as aaron and will
continue to commit atrocity after
atrocity until someone is eventually
radicalized by her and seek revenge in
this new catastrophic threat but given
the meta information that this is the
final season i'm inclined to believe
that things will end with gabi and her
generation and i guess i should say at
this point that no i have not read the
manga so i could be very very wrong
about this and just have very minimal
desire to read the manga because i enjoy
the attack on titan anime experience so
all of the margaritas can now proceed to
go
well he's or wrong in the comments below
but this is just how i feel at this
particular point which to reiterate is
that i hate gabi for what she did to
sasha but i also don't blame her
whatsoever your home gets attacked by a
race that you've been
led to believe all your life are literal
devils you then see your friends
murdered in front of your eyes and
gabi's reaction becomes natural if
nothing else and here's something else i
also haven't really seen uttered
anywhere in the social media verse as of
yet
as much as i love sasha she isn't
exactly an innocent victim in the
situation either sasha made a choice to
be part of an incursion on a neighboring
country that she knew
would end up killing countless civilians
nobody forced her to act sasha did it
off her own accord assumingly to help
aaron or in service of whatever crazy
plan
is in the works so sasha is a willing
combatant and
look i don't know what to say when it
comes to war soldiers end up dying
it's tragic and usually unnecessary in
the grand scheme of things but what else
was to be expected you can't just flying
into enemy territory with violent
intentions towards them and then be
completely shocked and aghast when the
people you've attacked either defend
themselves or go out of their way to
seek revenge on you so as much as i
would like to consider sasha in my
perfect little potato girl she is just
as guilty as anyone in this situation i
mean except for maybe aaron
holy crap i didn't think it was possible
for me to dislike aaron more than i
already did but this season has already
taken things to a whole new level i mean
i empathize with him to a degree but
he's just
he's so far gone at this point i would
be pretty incredibly shocked if he was
redeemed by the time the series ends
garby on the other hand i think we might
see go in the opposite direction right
now is our period of peak gabi hate but
after being taken in by the enemy there
is the obvious chance that she will have
to live with these devils for quite some
time and during that time gabi will
discover that
hey they're not all that bad are they
and hopefully with that sort of
perspective this cycle will end with her
with that said the other option is that
gabi is also too far gone herself and
that the cycle breakage duty is going to
fall to falco someone who should
definitely absolutely not be ignored
because he's already further on his
journey of understanding than i think
most characters in this world he's also
not completely irredeemable yet falco
hasn't gone and committed any brash acts
of atrocities so who knows maybe i'm
wrong about gabi and falco is going to
be our endpoint all i know is that
things are going to get a hell of a lot
worse before they get better
if they get better i think if is an
important word here but like i said i
quite thoroughly view aaron as the
primary antagonist of the series now and
if one is going to hate hungabi for
killing sasha then i think that at the
very least
an equal amount of hate should be
directed at eren for instigating this
whole attack in the first place but even
then it becomes a very vicious blame
cycle
in and of itself gabi was a victim aaron
was a victim rhino was a victim the
malians were victims long ago and who
knows how long it goes back the roots of
blame are absolutely endless and i think
that's kind of the point
trying to assign blame is meaningless
because at this point in time
there is no chance of justice for anyone
both sides of this conflict have
committed atrocities which have sparked
response atrocities which have only
further bred atrocity and really the
only way forward is probably to somehow
just
come to a full stop for someone to
experience hardship but then refuse to
retaliate
and that's why i hate attack on titan
because while i have no idea what's
coming i know that the ultimate solution
to this problem
if there even is one will not be
satisfactory it will require some sort
of painful compromise and that
sucks that sucks so bad but that's also
a very realistic depiction of war there
is no glory
only destruction and nothing to really
be done from that except pick up the
remnants and rebuild furthermore i also
hate the series because it has this
tendency of transforming characters i
love into characters i hate and then
turning characters i hate into those i
love but that's also why it's so
damn compelling because look as much as
i hate ugabi
i also kind of love you and i think that
you will be an absolutely fascinating
figure to follow going forward but that
pretty much does it for this raving rant
about attack on titan if you'd like to
see more attack on titan content then
please do comment down below like the
video do the subscribe thing
or even join the discussion on our
discord server but for now this has been
the new world review and i'll see you
next time